good morning Hank it's Tuesday it's been
something of a 2-star week here I mean
nothing's really wrong
aside from gestures broadly I'm just
exhausted on a few levels tangentially
related I sometimes experience a
cognitive distortion called negative
filtering where I start to filter out
all of the positive information and only
see bad stuff but the thing about
negative filtering is that like other
cognitive distortions it doesn't feel
like a cognitive distortion it feels
like only the negative stuff is true and
the positive stuff is inaccurate or
irrelevant in fact though the world is
complex and contains multitudes even
amid gestures broadly and today I would
like to tell you about two things from
this last week that I really liked the
first tank is your book of beautifully
foolish endeavor which I reread over the
weekend I really think it's the rare
sequel that improves upon the original
like it's really funny and heartwarming
and moving and it's this big adventure
story but most of all it's an
astonishingly sophisticated analysis of
what the internet is doing to us and
what that means for our social orders
like from the way Internet platforms use
our attention to the way online
experience can both humanize and
dehumanize others your book really
captures what now feels like for me I
mean obviously you didn't see a global
pandemic coming when you were writing
the book but you did see something
coming and so even though beautifully
foolish endeavor isn't about a pandemic
it has helped me to understand
contemporary human life as something
more than merely foolish even if less
than merely beautiful which is the kind
of complex and nuanced thinking that my
negative filtering brain needs right now
it's just so good Hank and I'm so
excited for people to read it a
beautifully foolish endeavor comes out
on July 7th one week from today also
Hank is doing a virtual live tour and
I'm joining him for much of it you can
find out more at Hank green com slightly
off topic but how is July 7th one week
from today when June first was both
three hours and three years ago
oh god time is folding in on itself we
need to move on talk about soccer so
Hank when I was 12 I was on my middle
school soccer team I was of course
terrible and rarely played but there was
one kid on our team who was really good
his name was James and he was from
England he told us all about football in
England he told us that at his
old-school there were lots of kids who
were better soccer players than him
which seemed impossible and he told us
that in England if there were
professional teams and the tens of
thousands of people would pack into
stadiums and sing their hearts out
together and he told us that the best
team in England was called Liverpool
Football Club and we believed him
that year Liverpool won their 18th
English league title and they would not
win another one until four days ago I
didn't really become a Liverpool fan
until later when the Premier League came
to American TV in the early 2000s and by
then Liverpool were a bit down on their
luck in fact at one point they were
close to bankruptcy but Oh Hank over the
years I have imagined so many times how
it would feel to win the Premier League
I have imagined where I would be at the
pub in Indianapolis where I watched the
games with other Liverpool fans at
Anfield maybe watching it happen live
but I didn't imagine what would actually
happen which is that Liverpool would win
the league after a three-month break
caused by a global pandemic and that
when it happened I would be alone in my
basement watching a football game played
in an eerily empty Stadium
could it have been better not really it
was pretty great
it felt magical I thought about the long
years since James told us that Liverpool
was the best football team in England
and I thought about watching the title
slip away in 2014 and coming up
agonizingly short in 2009 and I thought
about my friend who died a few months
ago who would text me after every loss
and say thanks for making me a Liverpool
fan you monster and I also kept thinking
about that great old line often
attributed probably incorrectly to Pope
John Paul the second of all the
unimportant things football is the most
important Hank I'll see you on Friday